انا افتكر انك انت الان لمست جوهر المساله
باعتبار انه
اولا انا لا اتفق ربما بكثير ما ذهبها
اليه هؤلاء الباحثين والاساتذه
اللسان العربي لم يكن طارئا على الاطلاق
في الجغرافيا التي تسمى السودان هذه واحده
الامر الثاني شاع لقرون يا استاذ مشاري
انه اللغه العربيه شاعت بعد دخول الاسلام
وانت تعرف انه في منفذين لدخول الاسلام
والمسلمين في السودان اليوم هذه الجغرافيا
عن طريق البحر الاحمر وعن طريق مصر
ولاحقا عدد من المؤرخين واولهم المقريزي
المصري المعروف
هذا هو زعمهم يعني انه
الشاهد انه عدد من الباحثين
ومن فتره مبكره جدا اثبتوا بدليل ماده
قاطع ان اللغه العربيه كانت شائعه قبل
دخول الاسلام في متوسط 300 الى 400 سنه
قبل الاسلام قبل الاسلام عرفت
وظلت هذه
يعني هذا التواصل فيما بين اللغه العربيه
او الاعراب ممن انتقلوا وهذه معروفه على
فكره تحديدا جهينه وربيعه هذه معروفه
لمعظمهم واولهم ابن خلدون
يعني اللغه العربيه
شاعت في بدايتها كانت خليط من اللهجات
واللغات المحليه وهذه كلها لغات افريقيه
يعني انت ممكن تقول عليها
لغات افريقيه بكل سماتها الدلاليه
والصوتيه
والتركيبيه الى اخره
استمر هذا الامر الى ان دخل الاسلام وخلاص
يعني يعني شاعت
سرديه يعني هذا الدين عرفت
وتوغل
وهذا كان عامل تاريخي في انه اللغه
العربيه يعني تتوغل اكثر عرفت وتصير
اللسان وتعلم ما قاله ابن خلدون
معروف في المقدمه يعني انه غلبه اللغه
بغلبه اهلها
وشاء هذا اللسان ولكن ظلت علامات عديده
موجوده يعني الان مالات هذا التواصل فيما
بين الناطقين باللغه العربيه
واللغات الافريقيه
وبالتاكيد المتحدثين بها هم من الزنج هم
من يعني الافارقه الذين لم يخت لطوا باي
دماء عربيه مطلقا وظلت هذه المساله لفتره
طويله جدا